it's a pressure cooker situation for
millions of women around the world
the coronavirus lock downs have simply
been brutal I'm announcing a CO vid 19
response task force on domestic and
gender-based violence domestic violence
is rampant in Russia for example where
up to 40% of all violent crimes occur
within families and reports suggest that
cases more than doubled last month Pope
Francis has meanwhile asked the world to
pray for peace within families as the
lockdowns endure but experts say that
women need direct assistance and that
includes access to modern day
contraception as unintended pregnancies
rise and in some countries maternal
deaths surged South Africa is gradually
easing its lock down which was widely
considered one of the world's most
severe limits on contact and outdoor
exercise kept more families inside and
resulted in a surge of violence at home
life is returning to the streets of Cape
Town but the sale of alcohol and tobacco
are still banned and tensions are rising
this is a self-help group for women who
faced violence under lockdown they meet
in Caroline Peters backyard she was the
victim of a gang rape when she was young
now she helps other women who are abused
by men
mr. Valentin please because we must
remember men are frustrated they lock
them in the homes they are agitated and
everyone is agitated an angry violent
men is unable to move around it means
that the violence is moved back into the
house rights of gender-based violence
against women in South Africa are among
the highest in the world and it's only
worsened since the start of the lockdown
according to these women they agreed to
let us film in the hope it would
encourage other women to speak out Kim's
life has been marked by alcohol drugs
and physical violence
she also says it's become worse under
lockdown everything you said I've been
through it too I have to tell you
something important so I want to stand
up I've made a decision and I haven't
told anyone yet
enough is enough I can't live like this
my boyfriend hits me in front of my son
I cannot love this man I'm going to take
my bag and leave
now's the time for action Kim's already
packed her bag but they have to go and
get her six-year-old son it's a
dangerous situation
Kim's partner doesn't know what's about
to happen she stopped taking crystal
meth a week ago and is leaving after 18
drug-filled years together he's stunned
but doesn't get violent
Kim has taken an important step she
reassures her son telling him she'll
keep him safe where they're going nobody
is going to hit anybody anything people
there will be kind and she's going to be
a better mother Kim and her son can stay
at a shelter for three months but their
problems are still waiting for them on
the outside and I'm joined now by
Calliope Eamonn Jiro who leads a UN
effort to curb violence against women
and Elizabeth Sully she's an expert in
reproductive health at the Guttmacher
Institute welcome to you both Calliope e
let's start with you we just looked at
South Africa but this uptick in domestic
violence is a global problem and what's
driving it thank you
first to stop that yes indeed it is a
global phenomenon we know that 1/3 women
face globally physical or sexual
violence and in the majority they face
this violence when it met partner
violence well what I didn't want to
emphasize it's not just domestic
violence the meter movement and other
movements they have clearly indicated
that violence against women and girls
it's a pervasive form of violation that
it happens everywhere at home at work at
schools when women and girls they are on
the way to school and to work and what
drives it it's much deeper it doesn't
have to do with some individual bad
actors and bad acts it doesn't have to
do with some random
but it has to do with power and control
and how abusers Excel control over the
partners and women and gals in their
lives the challenges facing families go
beyond domestic violence and into
women's reproductive health let's look
here the Guttmacher Institute says a 10%
drop in reproductive health care and low
and middle calm countries due to the
coronavirus would put modern
contraception out of reach for a
projected 50 million more women
unintended pregnancies would shoot up
same from newborn deaths and thousands
more women would die during pregnancy
there'd also be 3 million more unsafe
abortions Elisabeth wanna turn to you
here those are bracing numbers what do
they look like for women and families
this is just with a 10% decline we don't
know if that's what we're gonna see or
not that's potentially a pretty
conservative estimate of how services
are gonna be disrupted because what we
see are bad policies lack of access and
redirected resources that are all going
to threaten woman's ability to access
these services and it's not it's not
gonna play out equally in all countries
and on all women countries that already
have strained health care systems are
going to suffer the worst consequences
and people who are marginalized and
vulnerable who already had trouble
accessing these services those barriers
are going to be further exacerbated
during the coab in 1910 demmick and this
is really played out in a context I'm
sorry I just want to say you mentioned
redirected resources is that what it
takes to get things back on track here's
basically redirecting those resources
back to their original purpose here or
is there something more that needs to be
done at a time of these lockdowns
resources it's about how we are using
those resources the first is we need
governments to declare and make it clear
that sexual and reproductive health care
is an essential service that way women
can access this care during lockdowns
without fear of legal consequences for
traveling for care we also need to
protect and shorts to the plot we need
to protect and strengthen the supply
Cheng's there's concerns about global
disruptions and supply chains and so we
need to focus on how those are working
at the national in the regional level to
make sure that sexual and reproductive
health pharmaceuticals are making it to
providers and to patients we also need
to be we need to dispenser
pharmaceuticals differently so we need
to allow women to access contraception
without a prescription
we need to decentralize the distribution
of those commodities and we also need to
consider multi-month dispenses of
contraception so we need to change how
we're providing those services to begin
with we can also think about innovative
models of care that telehealth can
become really important in this time as
an option so there's space to innovate
and think differently about how we're
providing our care and then the fifth
and really important point is we need to
focus on the unique needs of
marginalized and vulnerable populations
that we need to make sure that they are
not being forgotten when we are trying
to ensure that sexual Newport of
healthcare is being protected in this
moment Kelly o P briefly I want to end
with you do you get the sense that
societies are taking action to do more
against domestic violence at this time
briefly if you could need to do much
more especially when we know that
service providers right now they face
immense challenges and if we consider
that the basic service providers are
women's organizations that they have
been struggling with financial
constraints even before covet 19 what
they face right now is even for them to
close down themselves and we don't know
in one year or in the longer term which
women's organizations will be there in
place to provide services for survivors
so we need to provide support tool to
women's organizations to continue
providing these services but also what
we need in the longer term is political
will and increase budget allocations to
programs that I respond to violence
against women and girls in the the
longer term all right we're going to
leave it there collie OPM in Jarrow with
the UN and Elizabeth Sulley with a good
market Institute thank you both very
much
time for your questions let's go to our
science correspondent Derek Williams why
do some Middle Eastern countries have
such low covered 19 death rates while
having a significantly higher recovery
rate compared to the global West
according to w-h-o notifications from
the Middle East and North Africa the
overall average case fatality rate in
those regions is currently around two
and a half percent of course those
numbers vary widely from country to
country but but many experts on medicine
in the Middle East like like a couple
who wrote a recent commentary in the
medical journal The Lancet also don't
believe that in general that reporting
is accurate especially in countries like
Yemen or Afghanistan or or Syria which
remain mired in civil wars and conflicts
it's correct that a few Middle Eastern
countries like like Saudi Arabia and
Oman have reported very low case
fatality rates and high recovery rates
if if you believe those reports reflect
the truth one possible hypothesis is
that a low average age in the
populations of those countries might be
playing a role but it's all pretty
speculative all rashes or hives a
symptom of covered 19 the w-h-o recently
included rashes and skin discoloration
on the fingers and toes in its official
list of less common symptoms for a Cove
at 19 they can range from from hive like
groups of red bumps to to larger flatter
lesions to a to a condition that affects
the feet that superficially resembles
frostbite what's being dubbed kovat toe
it still isn't clear whether the virus
itself is causing these symptoms
directly or if they can be triggered by
the body's immune response there's also
still a lot of uncertainty about how
common different kinds of skin reactions
are in different groups of patients and
and also on the timing for when they
show up the studies are ongoing which
medical professionals are responsible
for intubating a patient I couldn't find
an unequivocal answer to this question
but I can tell you what I did learn
intubation is one of the emergency
procedures used to treat patients who
were experiencing severe respiratory
distress some emergency medical
clinicians are trained to carry it out
in life-or-death situations in the field
because it involves placing a
ventilating too deep into your trachea
though it's obviously much safer to
perform an intubation in the hospital
where patients are sedated before the
tube is inserted so so I assume an
anesthesiologist would generally carry
out the procedure or a properly trained
critical care physician
[Music]